if you were asked to think of notable
crusaders likely candidates would
include richard the lionheart raymond of
toulouse or frederick barbarossa very
few would ever think of King Sigurd the
first of Norway who was in fact the
first King to personally go gallivanting
off to the Holy Land Norway which was
currently going through a period of
independence from Denmark had converted
to Christianity in the late 10th century
by the time of sick at the firsts reign
which he shared with his brother ace T
in the kingdom had been Christian for
over a century the Scandinavian world
had a pretty poor relationship with Rome
but the first monarchs to personally
take up the Pope's call to arms was of
course Sigurd you should be aware though
that there is still some debate as to
whether or not this was a crusade or a
pilgrimage Sigurd left Norway 1107 to
begin his journey to Jerusalem and
stopped off in England in order to
winter there Sigurd left early next year
without burning the country down a
conquering it which was a nice change of
pace and had itself to Iberia and Iberia
was at this point divided between the
Christian realms to the north in the
numerous Islamic ones to the South
Sigrid's fleet sailed to northern iberia
and took refuge in Yakov's land I've
always known as Santiago the lord of the
city allowed sigur to remain and
purchase whatever food he needed until
the winter came when he changed his mind
as such he had agreed to leave
peacefully and just kidding he sacked
the city and stole all of the food
anyway they passed no verson nowadays
called Gibraltar are made their way to
the Balearic Islands and it was here
that one of the most important parts of
the Norwegian Crusade occurred you see
the balearic islands were also Muslim
held but geographically important too
they were for the most part safe havens
for pirates but were also major centres
in the Mediterranean slave trade they
had long been a thorn in the side of
many Christian kingdoms mostly due to
raids on their coastlines and so when
5,000 Norwegian Crusaders turned up it
didn't bode well for the islands or
their inhabitants upon reaching the
first island Sigurd and his men defeated
the Pirates there and stole all of their
riches
the Norwegians then moved on and raided
the rest of the islands barring Majorca
which had a sizable population as well
as some decent fortifications Sigrid's
exploits here was circulated around the
mediterranean Christian world and
weakened the islands ability to resist
the future Christian conquest after this
the fleet sailed south to Sicily where
they were welcome to stay for the winter
in 1110 the fleet finally reached the
Holy Land in secret was greeted by the
king of jerusalem baldwin the first the
norwegians in the end remained there for
several months and received many relics
and gifts to return home
Sigurd also notably aided Baldwin in the
conquer
of Saddam by blockading the city's port
after this the Norwegians made for home
but they didn't go back the way that
they came instead they opted to head
home via the great city of McClure guard
or Constantinople as it's known to visit
the Byzantine Emperor once there Sigurd
gifted his ships to the Emperor before
making his way back home overland
Sigurd returned to norway by eleven
eleven where he was granted the epithet
the crusader and thus the norwegian
crusade was now over and whilst it isn't
a well-known historical event today at
the time Sigrid's adventures were widely
circulated and celebrated around the
christian world
he set the trend of King's personally
taking part in a crusade and continued
the trend of Seabourn Norseman turning
up off your shores and just taking what
they wanted I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to these patrons you can
see on screen for their continued
support and an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologists
as ARCA Flash Danny Maloney party-boy
Koch coolin Castleman Rob Waterhouse
Chris wicker Gustav Swan David Silverman
Winston hegwood Christian checky
Maggie packs Kowski Lexi Schwinn Anthony
Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell Mike
spinning three plates are on the white
and Michael Reynolds